hey this is this is kind of funny
um
we are now on rumble the right wing
network
we um we
they rumble claims to be the free speech
platform
everything's allowed it's all allowed
respectfully it's all everything
everything's just all good
so
we put some of our content up on rumble
we have
247 subscribers as of right now
we're just putting our liberal content
on there and we're going to see what
happens we're gonna figure out are they
really the free speech platform or do we
get ourselves banned do we get ourselves
shadow ban because remember all of the
claims that the right wrongly makes
about platforms like youtube
facebook where the right dominates
twitter etc
all the claims that they falsely make
we will now test on rumble
do they de-prioritize us do they ban us
whatever now maybe they don't i am
really interested to see what happens
you can find our rumble
page
at davidpakman.com rumble it'll redirect
you um and you know you can subscribe to
our channel or whatever if you do we had
a really good time during our stream
with this
make sure you're leaving comments about
just how great it is that we finally
have liberal content on here and
whatever that being said
uh
a lot of people are not thrilled that we
are on rumble
one guy who goes by the handle american
guy
almost immediately when we posted our
first clip showed up and said and here
come the liberals with their socialist
agenda to corrupt this beautiful website
we need to protect free speech
by banning these satanists and satanists
misspelled as well
um
that doesn't sound like the model of
free speech that the platform is founded
on doesn't
um another user said i think this is the
only left wing channel on rumble
well jimmy dore is on there i thought he
was left wing ah maybe not
um american guy then tracking us all
over we posted the marjorie taylor green
struggling to breathe while talking
about mask video an american guy says
she's struggling to breathe because the
demon rats keep forcing her and her
constituents to wear a mask but she's
there every day at the white house
fighting the good fight actually she
doesn't go to the white house and making
sure laws follow the constitution
um and then lastly
a user named parroncho
says you hypocrite criticize rumble in
rumble
while profiting from it
you must be another lib obama
fan
so needless to say
we are not exactly being welcomed with
open arms on rumble but it is a very
interesting experiment
and uh i look forward to seeing what
happens if we get banned i will
absolutely tell you and you can find our
platform there
davidpakman.com
rumble okay uh i want to make the
announcement we want this to be a big
community event so i'm starting to
announce it now
we are now
three weeks minus three days i guess
that would be like 18 days
from joe biden's much anticipated state
of the union address now you might
remember last year the republicans and
some on the right way media were saying
biden can't even stand for half an hour
he's not even going to be able to put a
coherent sentence together he's going to
be sun downing at night all these if it
was a completely normal uneventful state
of the union
this year
it is particularly anticipated yes the
right wingers are still doing the
dementia stuff but it's particularly
anticipated because number one joe
biden's approval rating
at this point in his presidency is equal
to the lowest we've seen in the polling
era and i mean you go back to lbj john
kennedy uh bush one bush two ever
uh the prior prior to biden the lowest
approval at this point in time was trump
and biden's approval is down as low as
trump's was so the real question is is
anything going to be done at the state
of the union to try to immediately
bolster that approval rating and one of
the things that i think is under
consideration this is my speculation but
insiders in dc are saying there is
pressure on this
some kind of renewed mission
accomplished on covid which some people
are very much in favor of and other
people are very much against if it
doesn't happen before the state of the
union i expect that something will
happen there
pushing a return to normality so we will
be live on march 1st starting an hour
before the speech on youtube twitch and
facebook i hope you'll join us and in
the meantime let me know on twitter at
deepakman what you expect to see
at the next state of the union
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple people are busy
we're not always getting effective
balanced nutrition from the food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag-1
by athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food-sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi-mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend in one daily
serving really easy high quality
bio-available ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple i've been enjoying
the ag1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good
helps me get everything i'm trying to
get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is in the podcast notes